welcome back keeping the community
healthy and fed that was the focus of a
special event in chinatown today
bianca holman explains safely giving a
hand to those in need the asian
community development council held a
family in focus kickoff event at the
chinatown plaza free flu vaccines
health insurance enrollment information
and boxes of food had cars
lined up down spring mountain road
organizers say with so many impacted by
the coven 19 pandemic
it's important to help keep people
afloat this was also a last-minute
effort to encourage nevadans to vote on
election day las vegas leaders like
congresswoman suzy lee stopped by to
support
normally we come here to this community
to celebrate
and seeing that now we are basically
supporting so many families who
have lost jobs have lost income because
of this pandemic but i think the thing
that gives me hope is the reason i love
our state and our city
is because we come together and help
each other out we are just as effective
as anyone else
and they don't really know how to
navigate where they can get support and
help
and that's reason why we're here today
not only to give out the food to the
family
but also to know what a service is
available the council will continue to
work with partnering organizations and
host future
family in focus events reporting in
chinatown bianca holman
8 news now